i have a friend who doesn't eat bacon so
in that case we might just put a few
extra on mine or it might
just disappear
[Music]
it happens
[Music]
hi everybody i'm david one of my
favorite things to do is go out for
brunch on the weekends with my friends
now that can get a little bit expensive
so today i'm gonna see if i can make
brunch for myself and five friends for
only twenty dollars that's a pretty
tight budget but um i'm gonna see what i
can do let's get shopping and i'll be
right back
all right guys that was pretty tough but
i'm pretty happy with what i've got
after all that we only spent 20 dollars
and 12 cents i'm pretty happy about that
we were able to find a nice variety of
stuff and we're going to actually make
three different menu items today we're
going to have a cream cheese stuffed
monkey bread
a mixed green salad with an orange
dressing as well as a blt eggs benedict
of course i'll be using a few pantry
items these are things we always keep
stocked in the tasty kitchen today we'll
be using salt pepper butter and oil i'm
excited to dive in and i hope my friends
are going to be impressed with that said
let's get cooking so the first thing
we're going to be making is the cream
cheese stuffed monkey bread what i'm
going to do is go ahead and add a little
bit of cinnamon to my sugar here we'll
use this in a bit after we put together
our cinnamon rolls and get them ready
for the pan you want to just kind of mix
that in there so we have that nice light
brown color and we'll put that off to
the side for now now we're going to use
some cinnamon roll dough today because i
wanted to make a super easy and quick
dessert to add to my brunch i'm gonna go
ahead and get it open
oh all right it looks like the cinnamon
rolls had a little bit of pie out of
themselves now you'll want to cut them
in half
so that you have almost a sort of moon
shape bring these two sides together
flatten it down with your finger until
it's basically back into a circle again
and we have about four ounces of cream
cheese here that we've cut into some
cubes you'll take one of the small cubes
place it into the center wrap the
cinnamon roll around it roll it between
your hands and then we'll use that
cinnamon sugar that we made earlier just
kind of toss it in there make sure it's
well covered
can't forget to
get a little pam into our baking dish
now that that's been greased we can go
ahead and finish covering our cinnamon
roll ball and the cinnamon sugar drop
that in there you want to place this to
the side and we can make a few more to
layer in the pan now this would be a
great step to ask for some help with if
your significant other's around or
someone that you love cooking with
definitely bring them in so you can put
together this delicious cream cheese
stuffed monkey bread together now we're
going to make a bit of a caramel sauce
to add to this just to make it a little
bit more rich and give it a really nice
flavor and for this it's super simple
we're just going to use a little bit of
brown sugar and some warm butter now you
want to whisk this very well try to get
all of that butter incorporated into the
brown sugar there's a couple of lumps in
there it's no problem just keep on
mixing with your whisk until you get a
little bit more of a smooth consistency
now we're going to pour this over the
top and then give us a really nice sweet
glaze that looks good now we'll go ahead
and pour this over our mixture try to
get a even pour as much as you can but
again in the oven it's going to
caramelize the sugar in there and it'll
spread nice throughout all right that
looks good
we're gonna put this in the oven at 350
for about 35 to 40 minutes and then when
we get back i'll show you what we're
going to do with the icing that came
with our cinnamon rolls
all right guys our monkey bread is
finished and looks amazing when you take
it out of the oven make sure that you
let it sit for about 5-10 minutes or
until it's cool to the touch then you
can invert it onto a plate like this and
we'll go ahead and get started with our
icing now another tip would be the
reason that we use that cinnamon roll is
because it comes with icing of its own
so we're going to just spoon this into a
small microwave safe dish warm it up for
about 30 seconds or so and we're going
to drizzle it along the top for again
another piece of nice presentation so
since we had two cans we've got plenty
of icing for this monkey bread i will
make sure that i get every last drop
because this is dollar dish and we will
make sure that we get our money's worth
a little bit of frosting trying to hide
from it we're just gonna scrape him out
all right i've got all of the icing out
i'm gonna go ahead and microwave it for
about 30 seconds and when i come back
we're going to drizzle it on top of the
monkey bread all right now we've got our
icing just a little bit more workable
and i'm going to drizzle this across the
monkey bread for our final touch
this glaze definitely makes the monkey
bread look perfect it's so
indulgent rich smells amazing now it's
probably going to be a good idea to
balance this out with a little salad or
something i'll be right back and we'll
get started on that
next up we're going to make a mixed
green salad with an orange dressing
we've got two oranges which are actually
going to be doing double duty we'll
segment them to place on top of the
salad and also juice them to make a nice
citrusy dressing so how we're going to
do this is take two small cuts first
you're going to cut off the top
and the bottom
and this will give us a more sturdy
workspace you don't have the orange
moving around when you're trying to do a
more difficult cutting technique now
you'll take your knife and place it just
under the skin
and try to work it down and around now
i'm not a pro so don't feel bad if
you're not able to make this perfect we
really just want to try to make sure
that we save as much of the fruit there
as possible and just get off all of that
peel now that we've got our oranges
cleaned up we're going to go back in
with our paring knife and try to cut out
these segments you want to aim for the
space right in between these membranes
that you see also it's very important to
try to cut angle down at a v from both
sides
this way the segment will free itself
after you get that out we'll place it
into our bowl here to be used later you
can just keep going around and slowly
cut those pieces out this is going to
add a really nice color to our salad and
be delicious for our dressing when we
juice the rest of it now once you're
finished you want to take everything
that you have left
and squeeze it with the juices into your
larger bowl because we're going to use
that to make our dressing in a little
bit we're going to repeat the process
with our second orange get all those
wonderful juices in there for our
dressing and finish up this salad all
right now we've got everything set up
here to put together our salad we're
going to get started with the dressing
first things first i'm going to put this
orange juice into a cup make sure you
use a strainer just in case a few pieces
of those segments got in we're only
going to need about a quarter cup of
orange juice here after that we're going
to want to put in our lemon juice and
our sugar and then we'll put this in the
microwave for about 60 seconds until the
sugar dissolves all right now that we've
got the sugar dissolved we're gonna go
ahead and mix in our olive oil make sure
you whisk all of this olive oil in there
for our double dip orange vinaigrette
now we'll want to put just a little
pinch of salt about wow
just two pie houses this time not too
much
and depending on your taste
a few cracks of pepper
and that should be good to go now i'm
going to put these to the side as i
assemble the rest of my salad
we want to make sure to reserve just
about a handful of these mixed greens so
we can also use them with our blt eggs
benedict now i've got some nice avocados
here because i mean what's a brunch in
california without avocados those
segmented oranges that we worked with
earlier again just gonna add another
beautiful color to this salad some red
onions for a nice little crunch that
should do it and last but not least i've
got some nice honey roasted nuts here
that we just chopped up and i found
these pretty much in the checkout aisle
where you'll see those little
grab-and-go kind of snacks i think it's
just going to give another nice little
sweet flavor to the end of our salad and
again make it look a little bit more
fancy than it is it's a dollar dish
trend right there i'm not going to quite
put the salad dressing on yet i want to
make sure that i toss that within the
salad right before we plate everything
and now it's time for the last recipe
everyone's going to be here soon so
let's make that eggs benedict
now i'm definitely excited to make this
blt eggs benedict to get started we're
going to go ahead and make our english
muffins
we're going to take this bad boy slice
it in half and place it onto our pan
like so so we're only actually going to
use three of these and have some extras
left over in the package so you have
more to use for meal prep the next week
or just to make another meal that's
another one of our dollar dish tips and
now we're going to move on to the bacon
we're going to use about two slices for
each of our eggs benedict so you don't
want to take these and just line them
across your pan now we could have gone
with the typical eggs benedict but we
thought that this little addition of the
bacon was going to give it just another
nice flavor and our fun little twist
that we'll put on a classic brunch dish
and now that we've got them ready we're
gonna bake these in the same oven at 350
degrees fahrenheit we'll put our english
muffins in for about five minutes and
our bacon in for about 12 to 15 minutes
until it's crispy and golden brown
all right now it's time to poach our
eggs we're going to be using these eggs
here which are again a staple within our
dollar dish meals because eggs are
relatively inexpensive they're filling
and you can use them within a lot of
different dishes today we're going to
use them for the poached egg within our
eggs benedict as well as within our
hollandaise sauce now since poaching
eggs can be difficult we're going to
teach you a hack using this muffin tin
you can poach a lot of eggs save a lot
of time and it can be done a lot quicker
now the first thing you're going to do
is grease your pan you want to make sure
that you put a little bit more than you
think you'll need just so that we don't
have the egg white sticking to the side
of the muffin tin now we're going to
crack our eggs in but you want to be
very careful because you don't want to
break the yolk
all right now that we've got our eggs
ready we're going to add a little bit of
salt and a little bit of pepper
we'll finish off with just a quick six
little payout
and one more paella
wanted to be gentle on that one and now
one of the most important parts you're
going to add one tablespoon of water to
each one of the muffin tins that has
your egg now you don't want to just drop
the water on top you want to try to
spread it out around the entire egg so
that it forms that egg bath and if you
have extra go ahead and put it on top in
the middle now we're going to place
these in the oven at 350 degrees
fahrenheit for about seven to nine
minutes or until that egg white is firm
and the yolk still has that nice runny
texture all right now we've got
everything ready to assemble our eggs
benedict the first thing i'm gonna do is
take my english muffins here and add
just a little bit of butter on there so
it has a nice rich flavor at the base
now i'm a butter obsessed person i feel
like if you love people you butter their
food imma butter your biscuit imma
butter your muffin i'm about everything
all right get a little bit more on this
last one i might make this one for me so
i'll put a little extra right there
after that we're gonna go ahead and add
the mixed greens that i reserved from
our salad to add a little bit of nice
color and flavor to our blt eggs
benedict we got the bacon the lettuce
the tomato i gotta put the ale in my blt
eggs benedict now that l stands for both
love and lettuce just kind of distribute
those evenly it doesn't have to be a
whole bunch on any one of them now we're
gonna put the tomato this will act as a
nice little surface for our bacon and
our egg now for the bacon we'll take
these and just kind of break them in
half so that we can fit them on a little
bit nicer and you'll take two pieces for
every eggs benedict now we're ready for
the egg
you're going to want to tip it over a
little to try to let some of that water
bath run off
and place it on top all right last one
the pressure is on
careful
oh that was close all right now we're
going to put together our hollandaise
sauce seems simple but you want to make
sure that you're careful as you put this
together we're going to start with a few
egg yolks in our blender and then we'll
add our lemon juice
and you want to blend this for about a
minute or so until you see a pale yellow
color
now that we've got the eggs nice and
ready we're going to go ahead and start
to add this melted butter now you want
to very slowly pour this in
as it continues to blend
now we're talking very slow i mean la
405 traffic slow
waiting on your income tax returns slow
um you know just molasses slow all type
of things slow you know that's that's
pretty much what we're looking for here
normally hollandaise sauce is made in a
double boiler but we're going to do it
in this blender to make it a little bit
easier the heat of the blender in the
butter will help to cook those eggs and
finish off our sauce now that it's
almost together we'll add just a pinch
of salt for taste and that looks perfect
now you're going to want to make sure
that you pour this on and serve it
immediately it's going to have a nice
thick texture and you just want to put a
nice generous serving on each one it
adds a really nice beautiful shine to
the top as well which you're always
looking for when you make that eggs
benedict
and we're just about ready for my
friends to come try this out now a lot
of times people will top this off with
some fresh chives or some paprika but
that's not in the dollar dish budget so
we're just gonna crack a little bit of
our free pantry item pepper on here
all right my friends will be here any
minute so i've got to get everything
else ready so they can try this
wonderful brunch all right well i've got
to say i'm pretty impressed with what
we've been able to put together here for
only 20 everything's ready we've got
this decadent cream cheese filled monkey
bread this wonderful mixed green salad
with a nice orange dressing and our blt
eggs benedict and two of my friends
showed up a little early so at this
point i'm gonna go ahead and see what
they think hello
how are you doing cooking cooking i mean
he's trying to do my thing you know how
are you doing oh yeah
it's good to see you this is a spread
wow it's beautiful yeah that doesn't
mean like two eggs muffins or something
nah nah we really try to go hard on
dollar dish you know you look good yeah
let me stop talking and just let you
guys try it yeah i feel like this needs
to be like a holiday or something let's
eat i don't know mm-hmm
i like how when it's when you could
taste fresh things that was just like
explodes in your mouth
it's just a party going on all those
flavors let me hop into this blt though
i'm gonna go ahead
now after tasting all of this let me
know what you think i spent on this
entire meal six eggs all right carried a
one on that put some tomatoes in there
i'm thinking probably like 50 60 bucks
okay i would just say ten dollars per
person
well being that this is dollar dish we
were just a little bit under that this
entire brunch for six people only cost
twenty dollars and twelve cents wow
this is crazy man hey hey everybody
come on in here and just go ahead and
grab one of those bad boys
i don't want to eat this oh of course oh
so much who brought champagne would you
need some mimosas
hold on this is dollar dish so unless he
wanted to drink night train wasn't going
to be
but um we'll work on that for next
season or something all right um now
that everybody's got their food one more
fork we need in the back okay
um seems like everybody's happy
everything tastes great and it's time
for us to have our little brunch party
so i'll see you next time hopefully you
subscribe below and thanks for watching
dollar dish oh yes
you